فكره تريند اليوم تاخذون الى المنصات
المصريه التي تناقلت خبرا عن تعاقد هيئه
قناه السويس مع شركه اسرائيليه لاداارتها
هذا الامر اثار جدلا واسعا بين الناشطين
الضخ الواسع للخبر عبر المنصات دفع هيئه
قناه السويس للرد ونفيه بشكل قاطع حيث
وصفت ما هو متداول بشائعات التي لا صحه
لها وتوعد رئيسها باتخاذ التدابير
القانونيه ضد الحسابات الشخصيه مجهوله
المصدر التي روجت لوثيقه مزوره بهذا الشان
وافقت تعبيره
وقد فعل مدونون على مواقع التواصل مع
العقد المتداول بشان استحواذ شركه
اسرائيليه على اداره القناه السياسي
المصري والبرلماني السابق ثروه نافع سخر
من الوثيقه المتداوله وقال في شويه مهرجين
جايبين ورق عليه اقدام
بتاجير قناه السويس لشركه اسرائيليه طبعا
كلام فارغ لكن اي هيصه ولايكات وشعور
بالتواجد المفزع ان كلهم يدعوا ان معهم
دكتوراه الصحه في فتحي ابو حطب على قائلا
كان واضحا ان الخبر كاذب اذا تعاقدت مصر
مع شركه لاداره قناه السويس سوف تنشر
الصحافه العالميه الخبر ولم تنتظر شخصا
مشبوها يروج لخبر كاذب بمستندات مفبركه
بدوره تساءل محمد عبد الكريم تفتكر عقد
قناه السويس الفنكوش حيكون اخر شائعه
تتعرض لها مصر في الوقت الحالي طب ليش شائ
الوقت ده تحديدا طالت اهم مصادر الدخل
القومي المصري واهم ممرات العالم على
الاطلاق